tonight many nevadans remain on
unemployment even as employers struggle
to fill
open positions thank you for joining us
at 11 i'm brian lofkis and i'm denise
valdez while that's the case right now
changes in accountability are right
around the corner for those on
unemployment
orko mana explains while more jobs are
now becoming available
many unemployed nevadans are looking for
the right opportunities
to get them out of the house and back to
work
i feel like we're getting taken
advantage of with our situation orianna
van dijk was
laid off in march 2020 and is now one of
the thousands of nevadans still
filing for unemployment she's been
applying for jobs and has even gotten
some offers
but she says companies are paying less
than her previous job so getting ui
benefits is better
i also don't think it's something that
especially someone in my position who's
a single parent parent and has two kids
it you know can survive off of welcome
to nevada's telephone unemployment
insurance claim
system an automated message from dieter
says there are mandatory appointments
for some claimants to review job search
options
participation is required to remain
eligible for ui payments
and starting on may 1st the work search
requirement will be back
it's very difficult to find any type of
person to come in
business owner juani romero is having no
luck filling six employee positions at
her coffee shops her staff is overworked
so she hopes those who are unemployed
will apply
i understand where they're coming from
you know you're making enough money
to get by and to have a quality of life
that works for you
on the same hand it's it's a
double-edged sword
van dijk wants to be paid what she's
worth employers need to
be a little more competitive with what
they're offering
it's important to note that dieter says
the work search requirement does not
apply to people
filing public claims reporting in las
vegas orco mana 8 news now
orco thank you as we mentioned several
companies are hiring right now
and many are holding job fairs we have a
complete list of dates and times
over on our website it's at eight
newsnow dot com